I know that you collect different kinds
of memorabilia but I didn't realize your
wife does it as well that's what's so
great is if people said to me because
they know I have a lot of nerdy [ __ ] and
they said did your wife make you put
that away and I go no she is the same I
this is a sentence that I said to her
once cuz she collects horror movie props
and I as Y thought I was the nerdy or
one of the two one day I said honey
you've got to stop buying movie props
from horror movies we're not gonna have
enough room for our vintage taxidermy
that was a real sentence and then I
realized that I had met the right where
our house looks like like a museum like
it looks like I call it a Victorian
gentleman serial killer is our aesthetic
it's a lot of old sign you said that she
has she has horror movie props she has a
what does she have an exorcist oh this
came she went to a thing called monster
Palooza while I was out of town once
it's a like a effects convention and I
came home one day and literally all the
poop of my body came out when I opened
the door and saw this can you show this
picture there it is yeah yeah and it
looks amazing by the way so this is oh
wait obviously that's a doll that's now
posed it when you you see that when you
walk into your house no we hired a
possessed girl Conan but I mean where is
it it was it was in the you don't want
to see that the first time you want to
house it down to where the TV is down in
the in the TV room but it but but for a
while I'd always know someone was coming
over because I'd hear the door opening
Jesus Christ like I would hear and every
day I knew it was gonna be there and I
took me like two weeks to get used to it
I guess so great to put that in a guest
bathroom yeah
[Applause]
you